.
- Vous avez dit : "Je suis très
contente". C'est énorme comme
défi. Et partout où vous
regardez au Québec c'est énorme,
mais il y a, mettons, deux gros
points chauds : la région de
Québec et la région de Montréal.
On va commencer par Québec.
Comment va se faire...
la communication? Parce que
je pense que c'est pas exagéré
de dire que c'est mal parti, la
communication du tation du tati.
C'est quoi votre stratégie
pour vendre ça aux Québécois?
- D'abord, je veux quand même
réitérer à quel point je suis
heureuse, comme vous le dîtes,
d'accueillir ces nouvelles
fonctions-là, de la confiance
que me témoigne le premier
ministre en me confiant un très
gros ministère, vous l'avez dit.
Effectivement. Donc, je serai
seule ministre en titre de
ce ministère des Transports
et de la Mobilité durable. Donc,
plusieurs défis. Prenons
le troisième lien, vous en
parlez, je suis en plus une élue
de la région de Québec. Donc...
Et je l'ai souvent dit, moi,
en quatre ans. J'étais ministre
de la Capitale-Nationale et
souvent, on me parlait du
troisième lien, et à chaque
fois, je répondais et
j'admettais volontiers qu'on a
un défi de communication
au sujet de ce beau et gros
projet-là qu'on a dans notre
Capitale-Nationale et dans
Chaudière-Appalaches.
Et donc, ce sera désormais
de le relever, ce défi de
communication, pas seulement
sur la forme, pas seulement de
manière superficielle, mais
d'essayer peut-être de mie
expliquer aux gens. Il y a eu
toute la question des études,
les données et tout ça.
Peut-être mieux expliquer
la façon dont fonces
gros projets d'infrastructures
au gouvernement, notamment
au ministère des Transports.
Alors, ça va me faire plaisir
de relev-là avec,
évidemment, le nouveau ministre
de la Capitale-Nationale,
excellent collègue Jonatan
Julien et le ministre de
re-Appalaches
Bernard Drainville,
qui se retrouve aussi au coeur
de ce dossier-là en étant député
de Lévis.- OK. Oui, oui. D'acco.
Vous parlez des études. Est-ce
que votre priorité, ça va être
de dire à tout le monde,
la machine, partout, en haut,
en bas : là, il faut rendre
public ce que nous avons.
On peut pas continuer à dire :
attendez, attendez. De jouer la
carte, pour les prochains mois,
de la transparence.
- Oui, je l'ai dit en campagne,
on l'a dit souvent. Les études,
on s'est engagé à les rendre
publiques, normalement début
2023. Mais là, évidemment,
je m'avance ce soir avec vous,
mais ça fait, quoi, deux heures,
deux heures et demi que je suis
ministre des Transports et d
Mobilité Durable, donc je pense
que tout le monde va comprendre
que je vais le prendre le temps
d'aller rencontrer mes équipes,
mon sous-ministre, mes sous-
ministres associés, les gens du
bureau des projets du troisième
lien aussi, dont le directeur,
pour essen comprendre
le fin fond du... Parce que
comme ministre de la capitale,
j'étais bien au fait du dossier,
mais c'était pas mon ministère
directement.
- Non, non. C'est ça.
- Donc désormais, ce sera le
mien. Alors, vous avez raison de
dire qu'il y a des questions qui
se posent. On va aller au fond
de l'affaire. Et moi, je serai
très transparente. Vous le
e pense, depuis cinq ans
que je suis députée, dont quatre
ans minitre, j'ai prouvé à quel
point pour moi, la communication
est quelque chose d'importan
Donc, je m'engage à communiquer
toujours plus et mieux sur ce
dossier-là comme les autres.
- Le maire Marchand et vous,
est-ce qlez bien
travailler en... vous allez
me dire oui, mais allez-vous
bien travailler ensemble?
Notamment son projet de tramways
avec vous et d'autres membres
du gouvernement Legault?
- Oui, tout à fait.
Puis ça, je l'ai dit à un momend
je parlais à des collègues
à vous, des journalistes, je
disais : "des fois, à travers
la joute médiatiqu
le jeu des déclarations à
gauche, à droite, ça peut donner
des fois donner une impression
comme s'il y avait de
l'adversité ou quoi que ce soit,
mais pas du tout".
- Il y en avait un peu.Il y en .
- C'est-à-dire que le fait est
que bien avant l'élection de
Monsieur Marchand, d'ailleurs,
nous, quand on est
2018, c'était dans notre
plateforme électorale.
L'appui au tramway était là.
À notre premier budget en 2019,
il y avait 1,8 milliard pour
que le tramway puisse aller de
l'avant. On a réglé la partie
du fédéral parce que bon,
un petit peu.
On a démontré beaucoup de bonne
foi, on a donné les documents
aussi, les autorisations
administratives nécessaires
que le projet continu d'avancer.
Mais c'est un projet de la Ville
de Québec, à la différence
troisième lien qui un projetdu ,
il s'inscrit dans la toile de
mobilité durable, vraiment plus
vaste, qu'est le Réseau express
de la Capitale, queeeeeeeee
projet au gouvernement, à portée
régionale, qui dessert
Chaudière-Appalaches et la
Capitale-Nationale. Donc,
pour nous, le Réseau express de
la Capitale, c'est ça qui est
important. On a besoin à la fois
du tramway, du troisième lien,
s sur la rive
nord, des voies réservées sur
la rive sud. Et le tramway en
fait parti. Donc... mais
évidemment, comme le reste,
je vais prendre le temps
d'approfondir les choses avec le
maire, avec l'équipe de la Ville
de Québec, puisque c'estun proj.
- Là, il y aura un feu à partir
de l'Halloween. Il est déjà
commencé, le feu, à étendre,
c'est le pont-tunn
Hippolyte-Lafontaine à Montréal,
et le problème plus global de
la circulation, des bouchons à
Montréal, c'est épouvantable.
Souvent, on entendait : "Ah,
les gens de Montréal comprennent
pas, à Québec aussi." Mais là,
ça atteint un point inouï.
des mesures
d'urgence à prendre. Donc, est-
ce que vous allez... est-ce que
vous vous engagez, d'abord
passer beaucoup de temps
Montréal pour comprendre
les enjeux? Ligne bleue, REM,
pont Louis Hippolyte, etc.
- Oui, absolument. Il a de très,
vous l'avez dit. Puis, vous avez
raison de nommer le pont tunnel
Hippolyte Lafontaine, parce qu'à
court terrrrrrrrrrr
défi qui va se poser.
Le 31 octobre commencent
les travaux. On en a pour une
certaine période de temps, comme
vous le savez. Mais il y a déjà
plusieurs mesures... Là encore,
je vais évidemment rencontrer
les équipes et tout ça puis voin
dossier qu'on suivait tous de
prêt au gouvernement, et j'en ai
parlé avec Monsieur Bonnardel,
qui était mon prédécesseur.
Il y a déjà plusieurs mesures
qui ont été mises en place pour
essayer, au mieux. Évidemment,
il n'y a pas de miracle à faire.
Mais pour essayer au mieux
d'offrir des alternatives aux
gens de Montréal pour offrir des
alternat
collectif, un meilleur accès,
des réductions de tarifs et tout
ça pour convaincre les gens de
renoncer autant que possible à
la voiture et prendre du
transport collectif. Mais on va
s'adapter. Ça va être quelque
chose qui va être corsé, on peus
pragmatique. On va s'adapter et
être résilient. S'il faut faire
d'autres on va les faire.
On a cette réalité
laquelle on n'a pas le choix de
composer.
- Je comprends que vous êtes
savez quelques-uns, on ne peut
pas attendre qu'un ministre
arrive vous n'avez pas tout vu
et tout rencontré. Mais cet
engagement de venir plus souvene
vous passez beaucoup plus de
temps à Montréal que vous le
faisiez contenu de vos
responsabilités qu
- Oui, tout à fait. Je ne m'en
suis pas caché j'avais laissé
savoir au premier ministre que
j'étais tout à fait prête àcédes
dans la capitale et là,
c'est le député de Charlesbourg,
le ministre Jonatan Julien
qui en a hérité.
Je vais travailler avec lui,
mais évidemment, ça me libère
effectivement.
Puis je vais continuer de
m'investir beaucoup dansale-Nat,
je demeure une élue à Québec;
la question n'est pas là. Et il
y a des gros dossiers à Québec
aussi, mais oui, tout à fait...
- Oui, oça.ça.ça.ça.ça.ça.ça.ça.
- ... la grande région
métropolitaine, on parle de
Montréal, mais la grande région
métropolitaine parce qu'on a
des projets Rive-Nord, Rive-
éventuellement peut-être des
choses en Outaouais. T'sais,
on a beaucoup de projets
d'infrastructures en transport
au gouvernement.journée,
là, je parle à la vice-première
ministre. Si je résume la
journée en disant : M. Legault
donne encore plus de
responsabilités à
rapproché  des... et vous faites
partie de ça, des ministres qui
ont des grosses responsabilités.
Il y a quand même 10 personnes
nouvelles qui amènent
une nouvelle sensibilité,
notamment sur l'immigration
avec Mme Fréchette. On sent
un désir d'apaisement et
ontréal,ontréal,ontréal,ontréal,
on sent une main tendue aussi
en disant : On ne peut pas
gouverner sans avoir une place
pour Montréal. Est-ce que
je résume bien l'objectif
de la journée?
- Absolument. J'aime bien votre
résumé, je vous dirais. Vous
dites "apaiser"; moi, je dirais
"rassembler". La main tendue
dès la soirée électorale
le 3 octobre, le premier
ministre était à Québec et
dans son discours, il a dit :
"Une campagne électorale, c'est
normal, ça divise parce qu'on a
chacun nos idées, bon, on débat
et tout ça. Mais une fois que
le résultat est tombé, une fois
que les Québecois ont fait
leur choix, quel que soit
le parti politique qui forme
le gouvernement, le premier
ministre et l'équipe
du gouvernement a le devoir
de rassembler puis de miser
sur ce qui nous unit.
Or, les priorités de notre
gouvernement, quand on parle
d'éducation, de santé,
d'économie verte, transition
énergétique, environnement,
identité, culture, je pense,
moi, que ce sont des priorités
qui vont rejoindre aussi
un grand nombre de députés;
pas nécessairement seulement
de la CAQ. Donc à l'Assemblée
national, on va tabler sur
ces priorités-là communes, sur
les choses qui sont importantes
pour nous comme députés du
Québec. Et moi, je vais le faire
dans mes dossiers en transport
aussi. T'sais, on a des
collègues dans diverses régions.
Des projets en transport, il y
en a dans toutes les régions.
Il y a les gros, gros projets,
mais ensuite, il y a ce qu'on
appelle souvent la voirie
locale, ou t'sais, c'est
un ministère très régionalisé
qui a des incidences très
locales.
- Bien oui!
- Donc je vais travailler, moi,
avec tous les députés, quel que
sois le parti politique.
- On va se reparler des dossiers
plus à fond au cours
des prochains mois.
Geneviève Guilbault, nouvelle
ministre des Transports,
vice-première ministre, mer